vous partez toujours d'un carré toujours
madame
non non le carré c'est quoi ça c'est la
base de tous les formes géométriques
l'heure du pliage pour passion l'artiste
Girardi Sauvan expose son zoo de papier
en origami à l'espace richos de
Versailles une technique consistante à
plier une seule feuille pour la création
de ses animaux papier peint pour les
éléments les plus petits et papier kraft
pour une meilleure tenue des grandes
œuvres
ça permet mais comme sur la deuxième les
uns superposés sur les autres et ça
bloque comme une chaîne d'un maillon et
comme pour facile il faut connaître
l'endroit où vous pouvez démonter sinon
ça risque de déchirer un travail de
minutie pour cet artiste originaire du
Cambodge des sons plus jeune âge sa
grand-mère l'initie aux bases de cette
technique d'origine chinoise il réalise
ensuite des œuvres de plus en plus
complexes sur des animaux une
fascination pour ses êtres leur forme et
leur couleur par exemple qu'un oiseau
je ne sais pas qui a créé pourquoi le
bec jaune
les yeux bleus les plumes
flamboyants c'est incroyable
j'aime beaucoup les oiseaux qu'il y a et
les chiens aussi et les minuscules
pliages de l'infiniment petit pour ces
éléphants faits de feuilles de 4 mm de
côté à l'infiniment grand avec cette
girafe de 3 mètres de haut ses œuvres
d'une grande finesse représentant des
insectes ont été réalisés avec du papier
de soie ça permet pour avoir les pattes
le plus fine possible aucun cours de
ciseaux le papier ça fait 80 cm de côté
j'ai plein de tortues très bien
dessinées et en plus il y avait il y a
aussi en origami des filets de mer donc
pour représenter la pollution de la mer
donc c'était très intéressant et un bel
engagement environ 3000 origamis sont
exposés à l'espace riche au de
Versailles petits et grands sont conviés
à cette invitation au voyage jusqu'au 29
janvier 2023